el corazón es un órgano muscular
encargado de bombear sangre que contiene
el oxígeno y los nutrientes que su
cuerpo necesita
las secciones de bombeo del corazón son
la aurícula derecha
el ventrículo derecho
la aurícula izquierda
y el ventrículo izquierdo
en el corazón la sangre de su oxigenada
con bajo contenido de oxígeno fluye
desde las distintas partes del cuerpo a
través de venas grandes hasta la
aurícula derecha luego la sangre se
dirige hacia el ventrículo izquierdo que
se contrae envía sangre del corazón para
capturar el oxígeno de los pulmones la
sangre oxigenada con alto contenido de
oxígeno sale de los pulmones a la
aurícula izquierda para luego pasar al
ventrículo izquierdo
finalmente el ventrículo izquierdo se
contrae y envía sangre oxigenada desde
el corazón hacia todo el cuerpo